Clark what would you say is is your
favorite episode or your favorite moment
from the last three years and and or it
could be you know what you're looking
forward to any of those things
woo woo okay um wow so many so many
episodes I've loved I mean from when
Nick Fury showed up and gave me back my
my favorite gun from the Avengers to the
kiss heard around the world
you know seeing Daisy become quake
seeing Mack get his shotgun axe it's the
only love I asked him for one thing and
he's wrote it for the circle he's taking
everything weird that was mine I'm sorry
I'm taking everybody secret uh Jeff Bell
your your favorite moment or or episode
from the last three years
easy favorite moment was despise goodbye
last year
Bobby hunter leaving and this young man
right here breaking my heart as they
said goodbye I think we can all raise
our glass to bobbi and Hunter yeah
ah Henry since you just got brought up
what was your favorite episode or a
moment my goodness I don't want to sound
redundant but it was a spy's goodbye
because for me I was not acting in that
scene that was very personal for me one
of the most personal scenes I've ever
done in my career because oh my gosh I
don't want to get emotional okay they
want it they want you to get him cry the
saying goodbye to two people that very
much care about it it was real uh yeah
and I know how much you like answering
questions so tell me what your favorite
moment was and I know it was kissing
Elizabeth but you can go ahead and tell
us actually I think it was episode 5
when you went away to the other planet
she was pretty I think we can all agree
she was pretty great sorry I slept right
now I am favorite also I got well I got
7 days off so I stopped by the pool
functions margaritas it was great
Elizabeth would you like to counterpoint
what was your favorite moment uh well I
don't know if this is a bad sign but it
was the first proper one that we did the
episode 2 of season 1 maybe it was
downhill from there on out I don't know
but it was the end shot when we were all
drinking beer and watching that oh yeah
it wasn't it just felt like the first
time this is gonna be a really special
family and we were drinking so it was
water water uh dad do you have your own
um they're a lot we've done a few
episodes now um I have a soft spot for
the first finale we'll all the finales
really but the first finale it was way
too hard to make and we had Sam Jackson
for you know I think one after one day
at the beginning the schedule but we
hadn't built any of the sets so we built
a small piece of the set and shot his
stuff and then a week later shot the
rest of the scene but that's an example
of how crazy that episode was but
everything always in the finales it's a
little too crazy and that the last
minute comes together like chopping off
your hand which was actually a piece of
chicken with
blood in it and and you know it seems
like we always come right down to the
wire the last second we're allowed to
film we're still filming then hopefully
it all comes together and so far it has
and and Marissa do you have a different
Ian stole my favorite episode but um
that's fine well he does deal with it
later at the time just wait till you see
the next scene we right through full
frontal just kid
please terribly please please he's
everything taken um yes that episode
4722 ours was a risk from the very
beginning just conceptually and it was a
risk across the board from the studio
well us coming up with it in the room
because it's a completely isolated
episode that features young miss
Elizabeth Henstridge being a super
furiosa badass all on her own on an
isolated planet but yeah I think it it
was definitely a departure from anything
we've ever done and I I hope you liked
it as much as we liked making it great a
very good script by Craig titli who I
think is somewhere out there so
regularly in the audience you will we
give Craig a big hand
uh Ming um hi I always have really a
difficult time answering these types of
questions and I I was racking my brain
and for me it's really about all the
moments and the process of bringing the
show together and just watching those
clips both Chloe we were getting so
emotional because we're like wow we do
this [ __ ] I mean we do this stuff all
right
and uh and so like for me from just the
table read that we do when we all get
together and we were discovering the
script and hearing it for the first time
to the madness of putting the show
together and then having kolpak come and
make you sit in front of a green screen
and try to describe and tell you what
you're pushing what buttons you're doing
and and that you're flying a plane when
you're just sitting in a cockpit seat
and then you see the final result of
everything with the music of Bear
McCreary and it's the whole process so
it's really hard for me to pinpoint like
a moment except getting hired for the
show hello and just to comment on those
table reads you can always tell when
Ming hasn't read the script yet yeah
because we'll get it to a turn in the
store in your hair like you're supposed
to read it she'll just look at us across
the table like yeah then what happens I
turn just turn the page Chloe what what
has been your um oh god I I mean same as
that what she said but I mean this year
the most memorable is probably the last
day of shooting it was a really
emotional one everyone was there and my
last scene was fighting was the big
daisy hive fight in the finale and just
fighting Brett it was really it was like
really heavy and all the emotions were
real and it was really sad and it kind
of it just reminds you how lucky we are
to be here so that was that was
memorable also flying in the car with
Clark member when we were on the car and
we had rigs hey Jeff Jeff yeah III do
think mentioning Bret Bret Dalton's not
with us this year yes and we love him
and he's been awesome for us I think we
should just all say hi Brett
a big round of applause for Brett dawn
I'm Viviana and I'm from Santee
California um my question is um what
personally was the hardest episode or
scene to film and why mm-hmm that's a
good question I'm gonna I'm gonna throw
it first to bunch of any day now go
ahead mr. Bell you're shaking your head
I'm shaking my head don't call on me um
some of this stuff Elizabeth shot was
out an Arri called trona
and it was about a thousand degrees I
thought yeah Elizabeth literally got
heatstroke shooting it and so and it was
it every day you guys didn't have what
usually I have at least two days off
every day poor me and she had act cold
which is the other funny part Hey
oh and she had to kiss in so that could
have been a hard day too Henry oh you
know what it is Henry oh really what is
it oh my you know what it is yeah what
is it I think was my my first season
second season where I had my character
had to go down a rope or something like
that
oh you it was when you were descending
into the hidden underground city it so
excited yeah well you're a big scary man
it's funny when you're afraid of
something
I don't like Heights okay they put me on
this rope and I you know I thought I was
gonna be all secured it was secure - oh
my god you might went up a couple
octaves
it was like literally eight feet off the
ground
just two more feet higher than you are
I'm gonna call myself out here I they go
Henry go higher go higher and I was
gripped with fear right and I said I
can't go any higher I can't go any
higher and my buddy who's my stand and
he walks up and he goes Henry I can
touch you from here
horrible horrible that stays in the room
were you surprised about how well the
strength of the female characters has
been mercy by the fans because I start
the police academy next week and I
appreciate it more than you could ever
know it's amazing and thank you Ming I
think a lot of people do look up to you
as as someone that inspires them you
want to talk a little bit about that
responsibility and and what that is like
in your world it's a tremendous honor
and it really it kind of blows my mind
because you know as a mom to have all of
the fans were young and old you know the
and and the older women to who and the
boys - it's it is it is an incredible
experience to get to play a strong
female character and then to have that
effect of positivity and you know the
impact of believing in yourself when you
watch these characters and and I know
it's it's just especially in this day
and age Marvel really does it in in such
an extraordinary heightened fashion you
know whether it's someone who's
intelligent and learns and discovers her
bravery like Simmons
or I also have what okay what does I
said some English what did I just say I
don't know oh did I say sorry you're on
it no no you're on it keep going keep
going
NOLA Cloe throw your I understood that
you're on a roll it was awesome I'm
sorry but you know and then someone like
a daisy character who who is kind of
alone and lost and rebellious and yet
you know having discovered her purpose
or just this otherworldly power and I
cannot tell you whenever I do go to
these cons and and having that feedback
it's the perk of a job that you know I'm
not a police woman I'm not a fire woman
I'm not a real doctor or a nurse or I
don't do things that save lives but I am
truly you know enamored with a job that
allows this connection with people I
have to say something because at it you
know attitude reflects leadership and
the reason our show has so effortlessly
folded in real life women characters
which are strong smart and pathetic
interesting women and it
I'm not surprised by how many people are
taken aback or I've appreciate it
because it's it's a reflection of real
life it just hasn't been shown in TV as
often as it should at all and a huge
part of that is because our showrunner
Marissa she is one of the most inspiring
women I've ever met and she know she's
leading the pack and it's been an honor
to kind of get to work in such an
empowering with an empowering group of
women Oh
hi I'm Landon I'm from here in San Diego
and my question is since Marvel's most
wanted didn't get picked up when or
bobbi and Hunter going to return to see
oh yeah yeah I I think we're best saying
that's classified wouldn't that be
that'd be the answer it's definitely
classified but keep watching hello my
name is Evan I'm from Diamond Bar no 11
my questions why did you guys have the
feeling to kill Ward and Lincoln
yeah why why did you have that feeling
to kill them well Jed why did you tell
Evan this little boy from Diamond Bar
why you felt the need to kill Ward and
Lincoln it's a really good question Evan
if we didn't like killing Porter we've
never regretted it more than right now
you know it's for us it's we're telling
a story so sometimes the story's got to
be sad sometimes it's got to be happy we
we love those actors very very much so
it was a very hard decision for us to
make but we felt like our other
characters needed to go through the pain
of that in order for us to tell better
stories moving forward and I'm sorry
really sorry oh we're really really
sorry Evan well I am and keep watching
you know there there may be new
surprises that make you even happier hi
there my name is Caitlin I'm from
Hershey Pennsylvania
hi Kailen from Hershey whoa um home of
the chocolate um it's your character if
your characters could go back to the
very beginning of the series and give
themselves a piece of advice what would
they tell themselves and maybe why nice
Wow uh why didn't you think of that
question Jeff
would you say so why didn't you think of
that question uh why didn't I think of
that question because I was too busy
talking to Evan beforehand ah madam I am
uh I'd like to I'd like to hear what
Khloe has I probably tell myself to not
date Hydra Nazi soldiers and then let
them brainwash me and control me and
then kill people and feed up Mac oh I'm
so sorry Ian would you if you could go
back and tell your character something
that's very big anyone would you have
told them the question probably
something to do with Braswell Awards
don't give him your pests away only
sandwich because you'll chuck it away it
doesn't appreciate it enough
hi I'm Tegan DeLeon from San Diego
Hyperion and my question is since we
unfortunately had to witness the deaths
of hive slash ward and Lincoln should we
mentally start to prepare ourselves for
a new love interest for Daisy we're
trying to cast that but nobody seems to
want the job president because they know
it has a extermination date I'm just
kidding haha everybody wants to date
Daisy it's not like look yeah do I have
a new love it's a really good question
yeah you should prepare mentally
physically everything you need to do um
you know she I think that she's rattled
from what happened Daisy so it won't be
right away but people people find solace
in other places and they have to move on
so prepare she needs Gallade what did
what is it Jim you got to get laid I
said I know hey hey you know sorry it
was like a statement for the children
lay down like a tab and I you know Jen
this is art we've already had this
problem yes Evan Evans gonna have a
different question next year
okay
you